so you're actually blocking your sensory
perception and and there uch patch and
UK
patch and as you know is the receiver
you're the receiver so swap over in this
case but but if you're the
receiver you shouldn't be even
thinking you're waiting for the LIF or
not so so by so so we like we I'm not
making the film yet so just go through
so here if we go if we go here um and
I'm thinking when's he going to
lift that sensory perception of
connecting never was never there in the
first place I don't need it if i s you
know B and that bow should have been
right yeah I think I F him connect you
see what I mean so so when we do when we
sort of do that even though it's for the
camer we shouldn't need it you it should
it should be
you I'm searching for it
now I'm searching for this okay is a bit
weak but I've got his
connection so when I do this this is
actually for the
camera so so we're going to go through
all this really fine
detail but what I want to do is I want
to film you first so that we and say
this is what we started with this is
what we ended
so we all see of a massive change
the longterm
memory I think you
said but because he's connected
this is here it matter about being over
his wrist in the
connection in the Practical mode I I
need to be
there so that's why I want